follis de pampelonne bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france le départ des chrétiens
d'orient et je cite un dommages
incalculables selon le pape françois qui
a dit aussi tout à l'heure il ne nous
est pas permis de faire la guerre au nom
de dieu
quelles répercussions après de telles
déclarations à mossoul où les forces
spéciales irakiennes sont présentes on
le rappelle oui bonjour merci pour votre
habitation
ce qui est extrêmement fort c'est que le
pape ait pu se rendre à mossoul
ça fait depuis deux ans qu'on parle de
ce déplacement et il a eu lieu le pape
était à mossoul ce matin a pu rencontrer
un certain nombre d'autorités ce qui est
intéressant c'est beaucoup de jeunes
nous solyom musulmans qu'ils l'ont
accueillie et qui se sont organisés qui
ont mis pas mal de banner est pas mal de
banderoles dans la vieille ville de
mossoul
et ça je trouve ça extrêmement fort dans
le message du pape et qui montrent qu'
il faut dépasser les clivages
confessionnels et et c'est possible à
mossoul demain de reconstruire une
cohabitation entre les différentes
communautés
pourtant la libération de mossoul il ya
quatre ans la visite du pape vraiment
avoir un impact quatre ans après les
gens ont envie de revivre comme avant et
de passer la table de doges
je pense qu'il faut laisser du temps
c'est extrêmement compliqué il ya des
rancoeurs il ya des haines je pense que
c'est le l'héritage laissé par l'état
islamique qui est qui est encore bien là
c'est ces fossiles de haine entre les
communautés et je pense que le passage
du pape françois peut permettre de
recréer ces passerelles ces ponts et de
refaire en sorte que les gens essaient
de revivre essaie de se refaire
confiance je dis pas que c'est simple tu
ne dis pas que ça se fera demain mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui à une vraie volonté
moi je vois beaucoup de familles
chrétiennes qui sont rentrer à new soul
il n'a très peu aujourd'hui en effet
mais beaucoup de voisins musulmans
viennent les voir ont demandé pardon
pour les actions de l'état islamique et
sont aujourd'hui très sérieux qui pousse
le plus au retour de leurs anciens
voisins et de la communauté chrétienne
on parle de mossoul mais il ya aussi
erbil et qaraqosh en ce moment
donc ce sont trois villes symboles
pourquoi avoir choisi ces lieux
exactement alors en effet vous avez tout
à fait raison ces trois villes symboles
si vous avez erbil qui la ville où il ya
le plus de chrétiens aujourd'hui qui au
kurdistan irakien qui est une ville qui
est totalement sécurisé vous avez
qaraqosh la grande ville chrétienne où
on a évalué à peu près à 25000 personnes
donc totalement chassées par l'état
islamique les eut un certain nombre de
communautés de famille sans revenus et
donc ça c'est un signe très fort de dire
c'est possible de revivre après l'état
islamique et de revenir et vous avez
mossoul où ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure où là il ya à peine une
cinquantaine de personnes deux
chrétiennes qui sont rentrés oulala les
destructions sont extrêmement forte
particulièrement dans le vieux quartier
de mossoul et les gens ne sont pas
encore rentrés en quoi la visite du pape
peut-elle avoir un effet positif ou
négatif a d'ailleurs peut-être ça peut
mettre le feu aux poudres en quoi cette
visite peut avoir un effet sur la
géopolitique du moyen orient
est ce qu'un religieux peut vraiment
réussir là où les politiques ont du mal
je le pense et encore plus au
moyen-orient ce qui est impressionnant
avec cette visite c'est qu'elle était
portée par l'église chaldéenne par une
des communautés chrétiennes et est ce
qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
depuis un mois un mois et demi tout
l'irak s'est intéressée petit à petit à
ce déplacement
on a le gouvernement irakien qui s'est
extrêmement mobilisés la société civile
est aujourd'hui ce déplacement ne
s'adresse pas uniquement à la communauté
chrétienne mais vraiment à l'ensemble de
l'irak et on l'a bien vu en regard en
voyant l'ayatollah ali sistani hier avec
le lait les prix inter religieuse qui
l'appuie organisée à tours
c'est impressionnant de voir que quelque
chose qui était impensable il ya encore
quelques semaines quelques mois
le pape a réussi à le faire et a réussi
à dire que hommes de bonne volonté nous
pouvons discuter et nous pouvons avancer
ensemble
ce ne sont pas des hommes de bonne
volonté alors
c'est à dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
jeudi qu'il porte ce message dépassant
les clivages confessionnels les clivages
politiques
depuis l'invasion en 2003 par l'armée
américaine en irak le pays c'est
extrêmement confessionnaliser et c'est
extrêmement morcelé et là aujourd'hui on
a quelqu'un qui rassemble et qui
expliquent qui vient voir tous les
irakiens au delà des confessions chiites
sunnites chrétiens cacaoyer zidi il y
aller voir tous dans leurs entités
irakienne qui dépasse les clivages
confessionnels et c'est ce message là
que beaucoup d'irakiens veut l'entendre
et particulièrement dans la jeunesse
qu'ils soient chrétiens ou musulmans
vous avez parlé de la rencontre hier
entre le pape françois et l'ayatollah
ali al sistani
quelles retombées de cette rencontre
selon vous concrètement est-ce qu'on a
eu depuis hier est-ce qu'il va y en
avoir encore est ce que les politiques
les les
et personne les diplomates peuvent s'en
servir je pense qu'il est encore trop
tôt pour pour le dire mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça fera date
c'est la première fois qu'un pape vie en
irak c'est la première fois qu'il ya une
rencontre entre deux sommités et deux
personnes aussi importante et ce qui est
extrêmement qu'il faut saisir c'est que
déjà il réussit à faire comprendre qu'il
existe des chrétiens en irak qu'il
existe une minorité chrétienne qui est
là depuis la nuit des temps
avant l'islam et ont déjà il fait
prendre conscience à beaucoup d'irakiens
qui n'ont pas cette culture là que leur
pays est une vraie mosaïque
confessionnelle est en fait que l'irak
ne se réduit pas uniquement à chiite ou
sunnite donc déjà pour l'ensemble des
minorités c'est extrêmement porteur et
ensuite plus spécifiquement sur les
chiites
on sait qu'il ya des tensions
relativement forte dans le nord
pratiquement dans la plaine de ninive
avec des milices chiites
eh ben on peut espérer que ce
déplacement ce message d'amour qui a été
porté et de paix entre l'ayatollah
sistani et le pape françois puisse
apporter un certain nombre de diminution
de tension est un peu plus de jeu me
dire de cohabitation scène dans certains
villages de la plaine de ninive comme
bart et là par exemple on peut avoir des
difficultés entre entre les communautés
loïc de pampelonne on a bien compris
votre message cette visite donc du
souverain pontife en irak
c'est donc un message d'espoir pour
l'avenir mais d'un autre côté est ce que
cette visite est ce qu'elle peut pas
mettre au contraire de l'huile sur le
feu dans une région déjà très instable
je ne le pense pas c'est vrai que
particulièrement en irak tout est
politique donc le fait qu'ils
rencontrent l'ayatollah sistani et pas
d'autres forcément c'est aussi un
message qui est envoyé à des défis qui
peuvent être plus à regarder de l'autre
côté des frontières que de regarder au
niveau de l'irak en tant qu'etat et bien
je pense qu'il faut reconnaître que il a
le pas françois eu le courage de venir
le courage de bousculer toutes les
embûches qui était sûr se passe ce sens
passage pour éviter ce déplacement il y
aura forcément des retombées pour
l'instant raison je pense extrêmement
positive dans les retours que j'ai dans
des jeunes kurdes des jeunes musulmans
des jeunes chrétiens et je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faut regarder les cris
les irakiens on nous a assez qu'on parle
de leur pays
avec des images de destruction des
attentes a dit ed est donc là c'est un
message énorme qu'enfin on parle de
l'irak avec son histoire le berceau de
l'humanité avec our la belle ville de
mossoul qui est qui veut est en train de
renaître de ses cendres et massages je
pense que c'est ce qu'attendent les
irakiens c'est qu'on dépasse un petit
peu la vision extrêmement morcelé et
extrêmement dur d'un pays en guerre
depuis pratiquement 40 ans et ça je
pense que le père françois pour
l'instant on fait un sans faute
merci héloïse de pampelonne d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes
l'ancien directeur de l'oeuvre de
lorient en irak une association au
service des chrétiens d'orient